nous vous en parlions déjà hier cinq
restaurants du loir et cher et de
l'indre et loire viennent de faire leur
entrée dans les nouvelles pages du guide
michelin
cette distinction parviendra-t-elle à
booster la fréquentation des
établissements récompensés pour
l'instant impossible de le savoir car
tous sont encore fermés alors quelle est
la valeur de ces étoiles michelin
version 2021 aurélie renault s'est rendu
à azay-le-rideau à l'auberge pommes
poires pour interroger ses propriétaires
fraîchement distinguer les appels et les
livraisons de fleurs s'enchaînent pour
bastien et emilie gillet depuis 24
heures ils font partie des restaurants
étoilés français
partager ça avec notre équipe ce fichier
à lire partager ça avec notre équipe
c'est exceptionnel parce qu'on a bien
conscience que sans eux bavon serait pas
grand chose
emilie et bastien ont repris la sphère
familiale il y a cinq ans entre vignes
et vergers
il mise sur la cuisine locale cette
étoile ils l'obtiennent alors qu'ils
étaient en fermeture annuelle pour
quelques semaines
décrocher le sésame dans une année si
particulière pour la profession
n'entache en rien le bonheur de l'équipe
on aurait été content d'aller à paris
sur la scène d'avoir la veste de voir le
président des mines michelin sort était
magique pour nous après en soit les
toiles ça reste les toiles et pour nous
c'est c'est quelque chose où c'est
quelque chose de grandiose quand même
ses fins et ça va nous je pense que ça
va nous propulser sur pas mal de choses
au niveau du remplissage du restaurant
quel est l'impact d'une telle
distinction
pour le savoir direction le quartier du
vieux tours dans l' agence de catherine
barrier
ici on accompagne des chefs dans leur
stratégie de développement et de
communication
selon l'experte obtenir une étoile même
dans une année ponctuée de fermeture
reste bénéfique
c'est une étoile qui disons dans un
contexte effectivement difficile
sanitaire permet de dire est d'apporter
du rayonnement et
et à ce titre elle a beaucoup de valeur
cette étoile et c'est vrai qu'à travers
ces distinctions immédiatement il ya un
coup de projecteur sur le restaurant sur
le chef sur l'équipe sur sur les
fournisseurs mais aussi sur une région
selon lagence l'obtention d'une étoile
fait monter en flèche les réservations
d'au moins 30% les nouveaux étoilés
espère que cet élan se répercutera sur
la vente à emporter